hallo ihr lieben
der herbst ist da und wir können es
nicht verhindern jetzt fängt die suppen
zeit an und heute gibt es von mir eine
leckere kürbissuppe und ich bin ganz
ehrlich ich bin nicht so der kürbis fan
weil ich dachte okay weil sich mit
kürbis hat sich so langweilig an aber
weil ihm der gewährte petit versucht mal
eine leckere kürbissuppe habe ich
gedacht wenn irgendwer das sagt dann
stimmt das dann muss ich das
ausprobieren habe ich jetzt uns gekocht
hat mir sehr gut geschmeckt und jetzt
gebe ich das rezept an euch weiter und
hier sind die zutaten und zwar benötigen
wir neben wasser noch ein joker ido
kürbis außerdem neutrales öl da habe ich
sonnenblumenöl verwendet pfeffer salz
und ganz wichtig ist auch gemüsebrühe
außerdem benötigen die kartoffeln
zwiebeln und möhren ingwer und wer mag
noch sahne milch kokosmilch oder
sojamilch
wir nehmen uns jetzt alles gemüse vor
und werden das schälen gewaschen habe
ich schon also erstmal stehen und dann
in kleine mundgerechte stücke schneiden
[Musik]
und jetzt nehme ich mir gerade den
ingwer vor und da bekommt er die schale
ganz einfach ab wenn ihr einen löffel
verwenden nicht mehr mit zehn teelöffeln
und dann ganz einfach abschreiben
und natürlich könnt ihr jetzt den ingwer
auch weglassen aber ich mag ihn immer
gerne rein in suppen gerade jetzt im
herbst in der kalten jahreszeit
irgendwie total viel magnesium calcium
und vitamin c und wirkt antibakteriell
und dann kann das einfach nicht schaden
wenn das noch mit in der suppe ist die
werde ich jetzt auch noch klein
schneiden und dann gehen wir an den
kürbis rand
[Musik]
und jetzt geht es weiter mit unserem
kürbis und das ist eine super rezept
wenn ihr das erste mal mit kürbis kocht
denn sie nehmen wir heute den hokkaido
kürbis da könnt ihr die schale mit
verwenden also total unkompliziert ich
statt ihn jetzt einfach auch in
mundgerechte stücke und werde ihn aber
die samen herausnehmen
[Musik]
so nachdem wir uns das ganze gemüse
gekümmert haben geht es rüber an den
herd hier braucht ihr einen ausreichend
großen topf da gehen wir jetzt unser
sonnenblumenöl hinein und dünsten dann
zwiebeln und ingwer darin an am besten
auf mittlerer stufe
[Musik]
so nach zirka zwei minuten sind die
zwiebeln glasig und jetzt kommt das
ganze gemüse mit hinzu außerdem die
gemüsebrühe und das wasser
[Musik]
und jetzt können wir das ganze gut um so
kann sich die gemüsebrühe auch auflösen
das ganze muss einmal komplett auf
kochen und dann geht ihr runter auf die
mittlere stufe und lass es 30 bis 45
minuten lang köcheln damit das gemüse
richtig schön weich wird
[Musik]
so ihr lieben unser gemüse ist jetzt
richtig schön weich und die jetzt können
wir das ganze pürieren
[Musik]
so die suppe ist schon fast fertig wir
geben jetzt noch seine rein also ich
persönlich mag mit sahne
wer das ganze fettarme haben möchte gibt
einfach milchreis oder wenn ihr das
ganze begann haben möchte dann auch
kokosmilch es passt auch super gut oder
sojamilch
und als nächstes wird die suppe nur noch
abgeschmeckt mit salz und pfeffer denkt
dran in der gemüsebrühe ist auch schon
viel salz drin
deshalb brauchte hier eigentlich nicht
mehr viel aber abschminken muss immer
sein
und so ist die suppe fertig und reicht
für acht bis zehn personen je nachdem ob
es eine kleine vorspeise sein soll oder
eine hauptmahlzeit und ich muss sagen
diese leckere kürbissuppe
die hat mich so lange satt gehalten ich
hatte vier stunden bis fünf schon gar
keinen hunger und die schmeckt zudem
richtig richtig lecker
[Musik]
und am allerbesten passen jetzt noch
kürbiskerne obendrauf geschmeckt richtig
richtig gut probiert es unbedingt mal
aus die genauen mengenangaben stehen
hier unten in der infobox ansonsten
freue ich mich wie immer über eure
wunderbaren fotos mit dem hashtag ins
kittchen auf instagram abonniert gerne
meinen kanal 4 und aktiviert die glocke
dann verpasst ja auch nichts mehr und
gibt dem video ein dörfchen nach oben
und kommentiert fleißig wenn es euch
gefallen hat und dann sage ich bis zum
nächsten mal auf die gis kitchen tschüss
[Musik]